let's start with a recap of some of the
benefits that play billing brings we
help you in four areas first we give you
access to users around the world
second we give you choice choices and
how to monetize in your app third we
give you tools in how to optimize your
purchase experience and lastly we make
it all effortless so you can focus on
building a great user experience let me
walk you through a few highlights in
each of these areas first let's talk
about how Play billing gives you access
to buyers around the world Google Play
reaches billions of users around the
world in over a hundred 90 countries
that makes Google Play one of the
world's largest mobile payments
platforms since we've met last year
we've grown in a number of areas we've
added seller support in thirty-one new
markets now developers in 112 countries
can now sell on Google Play we continue
to add new payment methods we've
extended our a wallet support to over a
dozen countries now and in India we're
in the process of rolling out unified
payments interface one of the most
popular payment digital payments
platforms in India and lastly we
continue to invest in our carrier
billing relationships we now have
partnerships in over a hundred with over
a hundred seventy carriers reaching over
a billion active mobile devices that
means you can now sell to over a billion
users on on mobile devices with mobile
accounts they don't need a credit card
they don't need a bank account they just
need their phone now let's talk about
how we give you choices in how to
monetize for a long time now we've given
you support in selling in-app purchases
so now you can see where you can sell
one-time items
gems or swords we offer subscriptions so
you can grant continued access to your
content or service and you can sell paid
apps where you collect a one-time
payment upfront before your user can
download and install your app a couple
of months ago we launched rewarded
products over a thousand of you have
already started using rewarded products
with rewarded products you can now sell
items to a user by having them complete
a monetizable action for example
watching a video rewarded products is
powered by our AdMob technology but
because it's now built into play billing
there's no extra SDK you have to
integrate rewarded products is currently
in open beta next let's talk about how
we help you optimize your purchase
experience the play console gives you
tools and reports that help you convert
your users into buyers and your buyers
into repeat buyers if you're a
subscriptions developer we give you
tools to help you understand who's
staying on your service and for those
who are leaving why they might be
leaving Angela will share more about
these subscription tools later and
finally we make it effortless for you to
earn money with your app instead of you
having to build a payment flow from
scratch we do it for you and because
users now see a consistent payment
experience throughout all a play in all
of their Play apps they learn to trust
our service and research has shown that
the more users trust a service the more
likely they are to pay we store the
users payment information so they don't
have to enter their payment credentials
over and over and over again and because
we store the information you don't have
to because after all you don't want to
have to worry about securing such
sensitive information do you
we take care of all the important
details in over a hundred markets around
the world for example did you know that
in the past 18 months there have been a
number of tax and regulatory changes in
over 30 different taxing authorities you
probably didn't know that because we
took care of those details for you and
that frees you up to doing what you do
best
building a great user experience so you
probably already know about all these
awesome things play billing does for you
so you're not here to listen to us rest
on our laurels so let's get to the good
stuff what's new with play billing first
off Stephen will come up and share a
number of exciting updates with the play
billing library the simplest way to
integrate with our billing platform
after that Angela will come up and share
a number of new features on our
subscriptions platform subscriptions is
the fastest-growing monetization model
on Google Play Stephen
[Applause]
thanks Larry let's talk about what's new
with the play billing library to get
started let's quickly recap what the
billing library is it's an abstraction
on the Android interface definition or
Adel which was the previous way to
integrate with play billing it helps to
enforce best practices and ensure you're
implementing the API correctly this
provides the best experience for you and
your users and it greatly simplifies
staying on the latest version instead of
copying a bunch of reference code you
simply change your build target to the
latest version and you're good to go
since our initial launch we've gotten
lots of great feedback on the play
billing library developers who have
adopted it into their apps have called
it a dream come true and we've already
seen many of you successfully using it
in production we recently crossed two
billion dollars in transactions from
apps using the Play billing library in
short it's the best way to integrate
with Play billing into your application
we want to continue to build on this
success that's why I'm so excited today
to announce the Play billing library 2.0
it's chock-full of new features to help
you grow your business first we'll help
you to access more users across more
surfaces we'll provide a choice of new
business models to help you maximize
your existing revenue streams and to
explore new ones we're providing new AP
is to help you understand more about
your purchases as well as adding tools
to help you monitor in real time and
finally we'll cover how we're making all
of this available now and in the future
to make things easy and predictable
first let's dive into how we're helping
you expand your access earlier Larry
mentioned that we have expanded to over
170 carrier partners worldwide but
that's not the only payment were payment
method were expanding today we're
launching support for an entirely new
class of payments that we're calling
pending transactions unlike traditional
forms of payment like credit cards which
can be authorized immediately delayed
payment methods require the user to take
some additional step in order to
complete the transaction so let's take a
look at this in action
in this purchase flow you can see the
user has chosen to complete this
transaction at their local si l
convenience store instead of the normal
tap to buy button the user is given a
payment code which they can use to
finish the purchase they simply take the
code to the nearby convenience store in
order to finish the payment and once
they pay the transaction we marked
complete and they're fabulous yak
adventure will be underway so now you've
seen how a delayed transaction would
work examples of delayed transactions
include cash and bank transfer such as
direct debit and net banking cash is
available today to top-up in Japan and
Mexico and we're expanding to in app
purchasing soon by implementing billing
library 2.0 you get access to these and
all other delayed payment methods
absolutely free it just works we're also
expanding the surfaces where you can
engage with your users to purchase your
content with support for out of Apps
subscription signups we work together
with you to surface your subscriptions
directly on your store listing page and
allow users to subscribe and install
your app in a single seamless flow and
we're not just thinking about
subscriptions here we'll also be
bringing this out of app experience too
in-app purchases imagine for example
being able to sell a special game pack
directly on your live ops page we want
to offer your content your users where
it's most convenient for them this
includes Android TV Google assistant
search and Google home just to name a
few
Angela will be going into more details
on this feature in a little bit now as
we expand to more services without about
purchases we want to make sure both you
and your users continue to have a smooth
transaction experience between finishing
a purchase and getting their content to
help facilitate this we've added
functionalities me added functionality
to allow you to acknowledge all
purchases with the Google Play billing
library or through the Google Play
Developer API this gives gifts against
Google a signal that you have
successfully granted a purchase made in
app or out of app to your user if the
user claims they never received a
purchase we now have it a definitive
signal to verify this
we can also automatically fix any
purchase which was made but never
received in order to reduce the number
of users who have a bad purchased
experience out of app purchases and
purchase acknowledgement work hand in
hand to give you access to a wide array
of new purchase services simultaneously
ensuring your users always have a good
purchase experience no matter what they
buy or where they bought it next let's
talk about some of the new choices of
monetization that are available in the
billing library we know that promotional
limited pricing limited time pricing can
be big drivers of purchase conversion
until now we haven't offered you the
ability to tell us about those
promotions now we're extending the API
to support returning both original and
promotional prices to your app and when
we and when we can we can show the
promotion directly in the play by flow
this means users will get a consistent
experience or consistent offer between
your app and our cart we've also added
support for custom SKU icon and we plan
to continue expanding this feature to
support even more consistency between
your app and our buy flow we're
currently testing this feature and plan
to make this more widely available soon
so next let's talk about some of the
intelligent new features we've added a
billing library 2.0 to help you optimize
your integration first we've made
optimizations to render the purchase
screen more quickly as we all know
latency is the conversion killer and
we've in search for instance we found an
additional 500 milliseconds of latency
can cause as much as a 20% reduction in
traffic and revenue last year we
launched a feature to cache and
instantly serve the cart as you see on
the right side of the screen
however today we're only we're only able
to offer this experience about half the
time with billing library 2.0 we've
refactored the API to ensure that you
get the zero purchase your latency
purchase at no additional cost to you
it'll result in a better experience for
your users an increase purchase
conversion for you next we've revamped
the developer payload to allow you to
attach your own data to any purchase
made an app this can be used in many
ways for instance you can
Hach data about experiments over running
for an a/b test or you can attach
information about an encrypted user
identifier to associate a purchase to a
user however you choose to utilize the
feature it's now available in building
library 2.0 and it can be attached while
consuming or acknowledging any purchase
now by show of hands how many of you
have ever shipped a bug to production ok
so about half of you raise your hands
and the other half of you are probably
in denial we all know that bugs happen
the best way to handle them is to make
sure that when they do you can quickly
diagnose and recover to that end we've
greatly improved the error coding debug
messages that are available in the
library instead of returning a generic
error code we now expand the API to
return specific granular error messages
for each class of exception this change
will help you minimize your debug time
and get things back up and running
quickly so now that we've covered a lot
of the great new updates available in
billing library 2.0 let's talk about how
we're changing the release process to
make it effortless to stay up to date
we've heard from you that our current
release process has some areas for
improvement first releases are ad hoc
and unpredictable this leads to
confusion on when you need to be updated
to the latest version further there are
two ways to integrate with Play billing
we haven't previously defined an
official best practice so it's hard to
know which one you need to use we know
we can do better here that's why
starting today we're excited to announce
a predictable yearly release cadence
every i/o starting with this one we'll
be releasing a new major version of the
library each release will contain the
latest features and API changes to
ensure you have access to everything you
need to keep your monetization strategy
at the cutting edge we're also
announcing that the billing library is
now the official way to integrate with
play billing going forward these
releases are intended to be effortless
to adopt into your app by simply
updating to the latest version and with
your bill target each year so you'll
know when updates are coming so you can
plan your roadmap around this
predictable release of course no talk
would be complete without a note from
the lawyers
as a reminder any of our road map
features are just that a road map this
should not be construed as a guarantee
the future releases I think I've done my
diligence but we know that simply
releasing a new version of the library
every year isn't the whole story current
versions of the API have an
unpredictable support window which means
you don't know when you need to update
to the latest version we think
predictability is really important and
that's why starting today we're
announcing the deprecation of previous
integrations with play billing adel and
billing library one point x but further
we're announcing that this predictable
and consistent deprecation and
sunsetting schedule each year the API
version will advance by one as we
mentioned a new major release at each
i/o within one year following each major
release new apps and app updates we'll
need to target the latest version of the
building library or higher so each
release will continue to be supported
for an additional year to give you time
to integrate to the newest version and
again going forward this process is
meant to be very lightweight simply
change the build target to point to the
latest version and you're good to go so
here you can see the two-year life cycle
of each major version of the building
library and because we are announcing a
new release cadence we want to make sure
you have plenty of time to migrate your
existing integration whether you're
currently using Adel or building library
one point X we're giving the full two
years for you to migrate your
integration next year you can see the
plan to release billing library 3.0
which will be supported as well for two
years and two years from now you can see
that building library 2.0 will reach its
end of life and all new apps and app
updates should be using building library
3.0 by that time this release and
support cadence will continue each year
going forward with each i/o featuring a
new major release being available and
and that's all excuse me it's each early
swing available and releases from two
years prior no longer being supported
for new apps or app updates and again
the lawyers do you need me to remind you
that this is just a road map so as you
can see we've added a lot of great new
features to building library 2.0 there's
new ways to pay new purchases the
surface room new models to monetize and
this is all brought to your users
faster with improved debug ability and
experimentation and the predictable
release in support window allows you to
plan your roadmap to keep your app up to
date a job of art of the library is
available right now at GTO / play / play
building library and C++ and Kotlin are
coming soon if you're interested send us
an email at these so we can get you on
the list now let me hand it off to
Angela to cover what's new with
subscriptions thanks Steven so you just
learned how the billing library gives
you access to more users different
choices with your monetization models
with an optimized offering and all in an
effortless way and now I want a deep
dive into one of the fastest-growing
monetization models we have
subscriptions so just a show of hands
who here currently offer subscriptions
in their app or planning to Wow that's
like a lot of you that's like 3/4 of you
so we've been talking about
subscriptions here at Google i/o for a
few years now and that's because users
continue to love subscriptions they love
it as a way to try out new surfaces
while having the flexibility to cancel
whenever they want and because users
love subscriptions our business also
continues to grow between 2016 and 2018
developers are like you have earned four
times more revenue from subscriptions
now you might think you know this might
just be from all the big developers
getting bigger I mean we can't all make
the Game of Thrones right but guess what
the number of apps with at least 10,000
subscribers also grew four times in the
same time period and so what that's
telling us it's it's not the big
developers getting bigger it's our
entire ecosystem getting bigger with
more developers like you successfully
offering and selling subscriptions
so how can Google help you grow even
more today I'm going to cover the new
capabilities we built in the
subscriptions platform to help you reach
new subscribers elsewhere as well as
retain them so let's start with reach
first
today all subscriptions are sold and I
and you might think well obviously
subscriptions are sold an app but
consider this probably very familiar
situation a user installs your app they
get to a paywall they're like I don't
know what this is so then they uninstall
your app and post a one-star review on
your in your store listings page and
they've never even tried your app or
consider this other familiar situation a
user is using your app for years using
the free content and they never even
realize that you had a subscription with
all this amazing content behind it and
so what if we could help you surface
your subscription earlier and maybe help
the user subscriber Lior too so I'm
super excited to announce today
subscribe and install this is a new
feature to help the user discover that
your app has a subscription subscribe
directly from the Play Store and then we
will Auto install your app in the
background how does this work exactly
well you tell us which SKU you would
like to feature on your store listings
page will offer this SKU and change the
button where the user installs if it's a
free trial we'll say free trial and
install and when the user clicks the
button they'll be asked to buy the
subscription and it when that's
successful then we will auto install the
app in the background now as even
mentioned earlier this does require the
new billing library we've been running
on EAP for subscribe and install for the
last few months with over a dozen
developers and we've seen some amazing
results we've seen an average of 34
percent increase in paid subscribers and
keep in mind that this is actually after
four free trial in fact photo editor app
picsArt tried subscribe and install and
they saw an increase in both free trials
as well as free trial conversions so
speaking of free trials through trials
again are a super common way for you to
acquire new users over 70% of new
subscriptions are actually coming from a
free trial but today free trials are
kind of one-size-fits-all when you setup
your subscription skew either everybody
on that SKU
the free trial or nobody gets a free
trial but so what if you want to be more
targeted for example what if you want to
offer a free trial only to users who
turn six months ago so I'm super excited
to announce promotion codes for
subscriptions in the Google Play console
you'll be able to generate one-time
promotion codes it's super simple
you tell us how many promotion codes you
want and we'll give them you will give
you a bunch of one-time codes in a CSV
for you to distribute to your users via
email via in-app purchase or other
channels that you can reach the user and
so how it works is if the SKU doesn't
have a trial users with a promotion code
will get a trial if the SKU already has
a trial then those users will actually
get an extended free trial so this is
great for targeting specific sets of
users imagine if you can send a
promotion code to a user who just
abandoned your buy flow or to a user who
churned after never having engaged in
your most primary feature in your app so
that was the new acquisition tools
within subscriptions but once you
acquire subscribers of course you need
to retain them and so let's dive into
the new features within retention today
when a user says I'm going to manage my
subscription what they really mean is
they're gonna cancel your subscription
and frankly there's not much else they
can do once they get to the subscription
Center and as a result some users tell
us when they're canceling I'm just
canceling because I needed a break or
I'm canceling because I can't afford the
subscription this month but I'll be back
next month guess what some of those
users don't come back some of those
users forget and so I'm happy to
announce that now you can let your users
pause their subscription instead when
you enable pause on the Google Play
console we'll surface a prompt in the
cancel flow asking the user if they
would rather pause instead of canceling
their subscription users which also
pause directly from the subscription
center for up to three months on a
monthly subscription this is a great way
to save on potential churners especially
for users who are leaving temporarily
so let's dive into a specific case study
Brazilian medical app TEDMED integrated
with pause and they saw an immediate
voluntary churn reduction of twenty four
percent with very little integration
work this is a great result now because
you know no not because I have to
deliver a message from our lawyers your
mileage may vary this is just a case
study so how do you know if pause is
going to work for you well last year we
announced a canceled survey that we
would show when the users cancelling
their subscription but this was only
available via the API and so that made
it difficult for many of you to be able
to aggregate those results and make
sense of the information so now we've
built new reporting in the Google Play
console you can access these reports in
the cancellation reporting section
you'll be able to see both the
aggregated fixed responses and to look
at trends over time as well as download
a CSV of the free form responses users
put in when they answered other both of
these together should give you
actionable insights for why users are
leaving and how you can improve your app
to keep them in fact language exchange
app tandem use the cancellation survey
to identify and implement new pricing
optimizations brain training app Nero
nation found out that through the cancel
survey that one-third of their users
returning due to cost related reasons
and as a result they're now thinking
about new wind back strategies using
real-time developer notifications so I
encourage you all please open your
console and check out the new
cancellation reports what you see might
surprise you ultimately it's going to
view a better understanding of who your
users are and why they're leaving so
we've talked a lot about voluntary churn
let's talk involuntary now so
involuntary churn is when the user turns
due to payment issues for example your
credit card got stolen or your carry
ability has a low balance this is a
super common reason why users turn from
subscriptions
and it absolutely can be a trust
sometimes with even dramatic impact so
we currently offer a feature called
grace period which you can set to three
or seven days and right after a payment
decline you will give access to the
users to the subscription to the user
for three or seven days while in the
background Google's retrying the users
payment method but why is grace period
only three or seven days for a lot of
you it might actually be worth it to
give the user a little bit more time in
your app in exchange for extending that
retry window we have to recover the
payment and so we've released two new
options for grace period 14 and 30 days
both of these will give you a longer
retry window so that you can reduce your
involuntary churn and the best thing
about this is there's no integration
required it's just checking a box so
let's recap what's going on in
subscriptions we've announced five new
features to help you both reach new
subscribers as well as retain your
existing subscribers the features in
bold are available today while the
others are coming soon now let's hand it
back to Larry
thanks Angela phew okay that was a lot
of stuff to remember so let me go
through a quick recap of what you just
heard today we're giving you additional
access to reach new buyers by adding a
new capability of supporting delayed
payment methods where the user can now
leave your app and go complete their
transaction possibly with cash or bank
transfers we're letting you start
selling items outside of your app so for
example via subscribe and install where
they can sign up for your subscription
directly from the store listings page
we're improving the choices that you
have in how to monetize will now
consistently reflect your promotional
offer in our purchase flow for
subscriptions developers we're adding a
new acquisition tool by extending
promotion codes to subscriptions and
we're helping subscriber retention with
new tools such as subscription pause and
longer grace periods we're giving you
new tools to help you optimize your
purchase conversion we're bringing
developer payload to the billing library
now so you can add metadata to your
purchases to do further analysis and
experimentation and once you've
integrated with a billing library you
should start seeing faster or improved
purchase conversion because the purchase
flow now completes more quickly we're
gonna help you launch faster with
improved error codes and now
subscription developers can understand
better why your users might be leaving
with the new cancel survey reports and
lastly we're making it effortless to
keep up with all of our changes by
integrating with the plate billing
library you now will have confidence
that you're always getting the latest
and greatest version of our billing API
to learn more about Play billing come
visit our team located over in the
Android sandbox and also over in the
gaming garage and drop by our office
hours if you have specific questions
tomorrow at 9:30 you can also visit this
URL to get more information
about everything we just talked about
and Steven Angela and I will be outside
right after her words right outside the
front doors if you want to chat with us
that's it thanks for coming to our
session please enjoy the rest of i/o
[Music]
you